[Musique]
je m'appelle karina guardian je suis la
déléguée ressources humaines de la
direction ene 10 en ile de france ouest
et actuellement nous recrutons des
emplois de techniciens d'intervention
polyvalent cette activité elle consiste
à venir dépanner intervenir chez le
client
assurer la maintenance et de
développement du réseau de distribution
d'électricité
vous avez des techniciens effectivement
qui peuvent remonter aux poteaux c'est
ce qu'on sait ce qu'on dit et qui
peuvent réaliser des l'interventions
d'électricité l'entreprise est née 17
une suggestion aire de distribution
d'énergie aux services publics de
distribution d'énergie
c'est ainsi qu'une entreprise qui offre
des perspectives professionnelles
importantes
vous pouvez très bien rentrer dans
l'entreprise en tant que technicien et
si vous êtes motivés si vous avez envie
d'évoluer
vous pouvez accéder à toutes sortes de
métiers on donne une offre de
professionnalisation et de formation
important
un technicien polyvalent dans son antre
et de poste il avoisine les 24000 euros
annuels en termes de rémunération brute
on recherche des jeunes diplômés
alors on vit des diplômes allant du ceap
et au bac + 5
les jeunes diplômés mais également on
peut aussi recruter des personnes qui
ont de l'expérience
pas forcément le diplôme est ce qu'on
recherche principalement c'est des
salariés qui ont un bon savoir être qui
ont envie de s'investir dans des
missions de service public
nous publions nos offres sur enodis
recrute donc elles sont mises en ligne
il suffit donc de s'inscrire à être
candidate et bien un ordinateur